I recreated the coal nuts from Pixar's
Elemental because sometimes as a
well-intentioned watery boy you just
want to prove that fire and water can
get along I obviously didn't want to eat
actual coal so we made a spicy sparkly
version of kahakuto which is also known
as Japanese crystal candy we used agar
agar to make a super sugary gelatin and
added a kick of sriracha since these
obviously can't actually be on fire
glitter and gold flakes really help add
that Lit from within glow and we did use
a few tricks to fuse these into the
proper shape and size painting on some
water mixed with activated charcoal gave
them the perfect burnt effect on their
somewhat crunchy exterior and these
candies are super sweet just like
ember's relationship with her parents in
the movie I was one of many puddles of
Tears in that theater so